my hand puppet version of the talk is
really very boring so was was worth it i
hope so i'm going to start by saying
that astronomy is one of the oldest
sciences this is a picture of a stone
tablet of the recording of observations
of Halley's Comet over 2,000 years ago
and this is one of the advantages of
astronomy that you can go way back in
the historical record and fight events
but even after thousands of years the
precision didn't really get any better
here too much more recent records of the
same comet but if you really want to
start to study the physics and
understand the universe you need
something a little better than this so
where we start to really gain in
astronomy is when we have very good data
this is one of the most famous examples
one of the early astronomers Tycho Brahe
hey took very precise measurements of
the orbit of Mars and then he gave them
to Johannes Kepler who he was actually
feuding with at the time but these
observations were so good that Kepler
couldn't make a circular orbit of Mars
work even when he had already put the
Sun at the center of the solar system on
holly's things he was forced to derive
his laws of planetary motion and that is
that the planets go around the Sun in
elliptical orbits and not in circular
this is one of the earliest examples of
a very good date in astronomy actually
forcing new physical understanding of
our universe now today I'm talk to you
about exoplanets the world of astronomy
exoplanets are very new exoplanets or
simply planets around things stars other
than our own solar system now 25 years
ago there were only nine planets this
was before we kicked fluto out of the
club after all and these were all in our
own solar system and then people started
to see very odd signals around both
pulsars which are very old strange radio
stars but then in 95 two groups two
independent groups claimed that they saw
a signal around a nearby very sun-like
star and that they had ruled out almost
everything else they could think of and
that the most plausible explanation left
was that there was a massive planet
going around the star and since then
we've had a real explosion we see if I
can make this movie work it's maybe too
much for the technology a real explosion
and this is just a little time-lapse
movie of the discovery of planets it's
their period around their stars vs.
their mass and you can see as the years
go on the exponential growth and the
number of planets and and in 2014 we've
had more planets discovered in the one
year that in all the previous years put
together and so now we can start finally
asking the big physics questions because
astronomy is really just about
understanding the physics of the
universe so simple things like how many
stars have planets how big are they
where they locate around their stars
what drives the diversity one of the
things that I find incredibly
interesting is we now know over 400
stars that have more than one planet but
absolutely none of those systems and one
of them has seven planets but none of
them look even remotely like our own
solar system and our own solar system we
have small planets close in a big
planets far out we've yet to find
anything that looks remotely like that
and then you can start asking even
bigger questions that go beyond
astronomy are these plans habitable you
start getting the world of astrobiology
and then the biggest question of all are
we alone so to do this we need to gather
the data on exoplanets because we really
need the hard data to do the physics so
I work for a group that runs something
called the NASA exoplanet archive which
is funded by NASA obviously and so our
mission is to try to facilitate this for
professional researchers so we have
things like lists of exoplanets we have
lists of candidates we have data on
millions of stars that have been
searched for planets which may or may
not have signals in them we work very
hard to curate this data by updating it
weekly when new results are available we
work for both grant work on both ground
and space-based missions and so we have
decided to use just things from the
peer-reviewed literature there are
things that are put out on the web there
are pre print servers there are blogs
and so on if you you write a blog today
and say I found a planet that's not
going to make it in our archive you've
got to get it passed at least a peer
review professional journal one of the
things we've tried to focus on is
bringing in larger datasets
maybe more work than a small University
group could do on its own and one of the
failings of astronomers is that when we
do new surveys we often give new names
the objects even though we know
perfectly well that all these stars
generally have already been seen in many
other surveys so one area in which we
spend a lot of work is was doing what we
call cross-matching that is identifying
an object in one survey with an object
and other and saying yes these are
indeed the same star and then because we
work for NASA one of our other primary
missions is to make sure all the
specifically NASA supported things are
preserved so that when the mission
itself is done the archive serves as a
place of the official repository for the
data so I could spend easily an hour
just talking to you about fun little
facts about XO plans but since this is a
data meeting I'm going to tell you some
of the issues and challenges that we
face and you know how we come up with
solutions and which are you know similar
to some of the issues that have been
raised before so our first issue is just
keeping up with a peer-reviewed
literature we're a relatively small
group and as several speakers have
already said today you know this isn't
something that OCR can magically be
solved because there's a lot of context
involved so at the first level there
last year there were roughly 500 papers
in the professional literature using the
keyword exoplanets so we had a scientist
read the abstract of every one of those
and decide yes this really is relevant
to us and we need to deal with this
paper we then have to go in extract all
the relevant data validate it and get it
into the archive get you into the
archive is easy it's the extracting and
the validating that's difficult so some
of the issues that we have you know it's
different than the insurance maps that
we heard about earlier but we do have
our own issues another failing of
astronomers is we can't agree to all use
the same units in the same reference
points so I have a little table here of
just just within the chime system called
Julian date there are four systems that
people use and there's a whole nother
system of times that people eat so you
have to figure out what mean when
someone gives a date in astronomy you
have to figure out what kind of
is this because in the archive we need
to put that on a common reference frame
so that all the data can be compared
another problem is that people aren't
necessarily thinking that this is going
to go and into an archive and so very
important data will just be embedded in
text and so again there's no easy way to
get that out other than very manually so
we have dedicated our Chi staff that
this is all that they do we are working
to make this better in our field working
with some of the other astronomy data
archives to try to set standards for
people we're hoping that if we actually
have templates and guidelines people
will try to be a little better about
getting their data in a format that
makes it much easier for the long-term
preservation the second problem and this
is somewhat specific to exoplanets
because several of those questions I
asked you want to know not only where
the planets are but you want to know
where the planets are not so if you want
to answer the question how many stars
have planets I not only need to know how
many planets you found but I need to
know how many stars you looked at an
ideally which stars you looked at
because then I can compare it to this
other study which looked at in some a
lot but not completely overlapping set
but right now in academia it's very
competitive there's many more postdocs
than there are faculty positions and
there's a lot of social pressure i'll
call it to publish just the positive
results and so if someone will say
they'll do a survey of a thousand stars
they'll find five planets and they'll
publish that and we'll get that data in
the archive but they won't publish the
list of the non-detection zaz we call
them and we and we have relatively low
detection rates here up to a few percent
at best and so there there are many many
more stars that have been searched then
planets have been found if we don't know
that we're really incomplete in our
knowledge so the long-term thing is you
need to change the culture and you know
we're working on that but that's hard
for any one group to do in the short
term we're trying to give essentially
financial incentives we have a little
bit of grant money we can give someone
to give their graduate student you know
will help you pay your page charges but
that's very intensive as well we have to
do that one on one group
but you know we are making a little
progress that way the third issue is
about data diversity and this is perhaps
the most interesting one because it's
not clear to me what the solution is so
there are many methods of discovering
planets and I'll tell you a little bit
about some of them but each of them maze
is a different sub subset of the
physical properties that were interested
in and no single method gets them all
and so here's just a sort of summary of
the kinds of things we're interested we
want to know what the central star is we
want to know what the planet is
particularly its mass and radius because
then you can do density and Composition
we want to know how far it is from the
central star how long it takes to go
around now we go through the four most
prolific methods of planet discovery so
the first is transits these are ranked
in order of the number of planets that
have been found in it so this is very
simple you have a bright star the planet
passes in front the planet isn't self
luminous and so it's now blocking light
so you get a little less light from the
star when the planets in front of it so
this is very simple it's simple to
subscribe at least it's actually hard to
do in practice because very little light
is blocked but you also have to have the
alignment of the planets orbit with the
line of sight to earth so this has a
very low rate of success just naturally
because even if you have a lot of
planets most of them won't be aligned
with this line of sight the second is
the maybe the most famous method because
this is the the most common for the
first 15 years of finding planets and
that's called radial velocity or wobble
you have the gravitational influence of
the planet as it goes around the star
that's actually enough that the star is
actually moving and so you can see a
shift in the spectrum of the star if you
observe it and so this is not relied on
the inclination angle so as much more as
a higher rate of success the third is
the most direct and the most recent so
this is imaging so this is very simple
these are the only real astronomical
images I'm showing this whole talk these
are actual exoplanet systems the one
difficulty about this one is that the
star is so much brighter than the play
and it's and you're seeing the planets
and reflected light not in direct
emission from them it requires
relatively sophisticated methods of
blocking the light from the star that's
why the images look a little funny in
the center those are spots that the
light from the star has been subtracted
by various means but what you're left
with is just a direct picture of the
exoplanets and then finally probably the
most obscure method of these four main
ones is called microlensing this
actually invokes relativity and the
gravitational distortion of light you
have a very distant star and a somewhat
near one the light from the distant star
will be warped and you'll get a
momentary increase in light as the star
in between passes by if that star in
between then has a planet you get a
little blip on that signal from the
gravitational influence on the distant
stars light so this is a very obscure
but it's actually very powerful because
as I'll show you it proves a different
kind of planet than the other methods ok
so now going back to this idea of the
subsets of physical properties that
we're trying to find out we can look at
each of these four methods so the
transits for which we've found many
planets are great except you have no
idea what the masses you can see what
the size is because you can see that
light is blocked but you have no idea
what the masses then conversely rate of
velocity which accounts for the other
big chunk here you get a mass although
you have a ambiguity due to the sign of
the inclination but you have no idea
what the radiuses so these are two
fundamental properties of any planet and
the two big methods don't don't together
don't measure them imaging and
microlensing are very similar and that
it's somewhat model dependent on getting
these things out so what happens when
you make a table of all these planets as
we have done which you end up is with a
somewhat sparsely populated table so
this is a real snapshot of known
exoplanets gives you a favor of how
badly astronomers named objects but also
gives you a flavor of all those blank
blank cells or where there is no data in
the literature and in fact is unlikely
ever to be data in the literature for
those quantities so we have this issue
now as scientists
how are we going to actually ask and
answer these big physics questions
without being able to populate this data
so in some ways there is no solution to
part of the problem because it's just
fundamental to the fact that these
discovery methods are different and and
you you can't always use the same method
on on planets so this is now phase space
of period versus mass for planets and
the four methods roughly with their
current sensitivities you can see
there's a relatively large overlap
between the transits and the radio
velocity methods but remember the
transits only happen if their edge on
orbitz and so in fact there is
relatively little overlap and then the
other methods they you know it's great
that they probe different areas but it's
bad it means that very few planets have
all these physical properties measured
and you can see that now if i plot up
the real data on those same axes they're
not now they're color-coded by these
different methods you can see there's
very little overlap between these
samples and so anyone looking to study
these samples is going to really have to
take that into account and so what have
we done I mean we can't solve the
fundamental proper the fundamental issue
of taking data where it just can't be
done but we're trying to work with with
researchers to do the best that we can
we allow them to do sub-samples we
always link to the original data and
source we provide counts for those doing
statistical work and here's just an
example if you of a group working on
what we call population synthesis
they're trying to understand the big
questions of exoplanets by starting from
from the physics of how they form and
then looking at the observed population
and then they do a comparison to the sub
samples after they've applied these
biases and this is where the archive
whoops this is where the archive comes
in we allow them to select out the
different properties and the different
samples to compare to so I just want to
end with on a somewhat upbeat note there
are some planets where we do actually
know everything that we need to start
asking the really interesting physics
question
so there are those planets which both
transit and have had radial velocity
data taken and from that you can get
both the mass and the radius and that's
incredibly important because then you
get density and density is actually when
you can start comparing two things that
we understand here on earth so here's a
little plot of some of the better-known
better characterize small planets so you
can see Earth and Venus down there in
the corner and then the lines are lines
of constant density and the bottom red
line would be a world made up entirely
of iron so that's basically the most
dense thing that we can imagine
realistically forming around another
star and you can see nothing is
particularly close to that line and then
the top blue line is is majority water
with some other minerals and you can see
there are quite a few things up but when
the interesting things here is
particularly when you look at the
position of Earth and Venus which are
planets that we hopefully understand
relatively well you can see there's a
huge range there's this world called
Kepler 11f way up there at the top there
much much less dense than any of the
small worlds in our own solar system and
so now we can start finding out you know
what's you know trying to ask the
questions why why is that how way to
that form why is it so different than
the worlds that we have here and then
from those gold standards there's even a
better set the brightest ones that are
nearest to earth we can actually do a
method of detecting what's in their
atmospheres now not all of them have
atmospheres but a few of them do and
we've gone to the point we've detected
molecules in the atmospheres around
planets around other stars this is just
beginning and as a area very active
research in astronomy but we've we found
some of the basic molecules water carbon
oxide carbon dioxide methane and we're
building up a library again we haven't
found anything that looks like any of
the planets in our own solar system and
so it's opening up even more questions
of why is that you know why is our solar
system like it is in fact and so this is
an area where we're it's there's going
to be a lot of new to
govers in the next several years so I
know I'm standing between you and lunch
so let me just sum up by saying that you
know in the last 25 years we've
discovered over 1,700 planets around
other stars but the process of really
understanding them is only just
beginning because we've only just gotten
to the point where we have enough data
to actually start challenging physical
hypotheses against this data and so what
that requires not only preserving the
data which is really not that difficult
but actually understanding its concerts
context and the biases which is turning
out to be a much more difficult problem
I will end in an optimistic note in the
exoplanets are very big right now and
there are many many missions both in the
planning stages and underway that are
going to expand are these counts
tremendously over the next three years
these are just three that I'm
highlighting because they're large space
missions but once they're done we're
going to have tens of thousands of
exoplanets that we know thank you